so we just got even more new things for
Avengers fort now we have promo posters
I think these are coming out because I
definitely think that these are for toys
that they're making for Avengers 4 and
what they did here is they took the
first official leaked promo photo that
we've seen for Avengers 4 and they just
kind of rearranged it in different
fashion here and I think the theme here
is pretty easy to catch on to it's blue
and red so it's Captain America and Iron
Man and I hate to say it but I think
this could very well be a tribute to two
of our favorite Avengers that really
won't make it past Avengers 4 I'm not
saying that they're gonna die but I'm
saying that this is probably gonna be
their last movie at least as main
characters they might come back and do
cameos if they do survive Avengers 4 but
I think this is it from so looking at
this blue poster it's clearly kind of a
tribute to Captain America you can see
his picture and middle on the top there
it's a tribute to him what we obviously
noticed the most is that Captain
America's beard is gone he is no longer
nomad Captain America he has the white
star back on his chest and if you look
close enough you can see that he's
wearing his scale armor basically it
looks like Captain America will again
pick up the mantle of Captain America in
Avengers 4 which makes sense because if
this is his last movie he'd want to end
it as Captain America instead of like
Avengers infinity war where he was the
Nomad and then of course on these other
posters we have red which is a tribute
to Iron Man he is in his bleeding-edge
armor of course but one thing
interesting is that in the bottom right
of this Captain America is in red maybe
this is a little foreshadowing at a
soulstone sacrifice maybe just an and
something that's really new is that
poster in the middle with the black
background you see Thanos on top and we
have ant-man now the picture for Thanos
obviously came from the promotional
photo that was released a couple of
weeks ago but we did not have ant-man in
that promotional photo what I'm about to
say is kind of a spoiler for ant-man on
the wasp slash Avengers
but not really you should probably know
this already if you've been keeping up
but a chance to turn away we all know
that ant-man survives down as a snap
ant-man is going to be a key for the
Avengers traveling through time using
the quantum realm technology that will
be introduced to us in ant-man and the
wasp these posters are kind of retro
which i think is really cool I think
that's like a throwback to the og
Avengers with the exception of you know
a few of them like nebula rocket racoon
Captain Marvel who aren't original
Avengers but I really like these posters
I like the colors I like how it's for
Captain America and for Iron Man I like
I like threw ant-man in there and how
they threw Thanos in there for one of
the pictures on the poster and I hope
these are available soon so that's it
for these what do you all think about
these brand-new posters and do you think
they are foreshadowing anything hit me
with your thoughts in the comments below
and of course don't forget to like this
video before you leave and subscribe to
my channel so you can stay up to date on
all things related to Avengers 4 Marvel
DC and superhero thank you so much for
watching Wolfgang woof-woof
[Music]